Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Benim ismim Uluç Kadıoğlu.
3 Şubat 2000 yılında
Bodrum'da doğdum.
Zaten tanıtıldım.
Biraz gencim gördüğünüz üzere.
Biyoloji ve siyasetle ilgileniyorum,
ikisi de çok ayrı bir konu olmasına rağmen
ikisiyle de çok ilgiliyim.
Ama benim çocukluğum çok güzel geçti,
bundan bahsetmem gerekiyor
birazcık sizlere.
Benimle sürekli
ilgilenen bir ailem vardı.
Annem özellikle
benim eğitimime çok destek verdi,
sürekli bana sorgulamayı aşılattı.
Kendisi orada bir yerde,
teşekkür ediyorum göremiyorum şu anda.
Ama tabii bir de şunu hatırlıyorum
bir anektod.
Bana bir mikroskop almıştı ailem
çok küçükken.
Ben bu mikroskopla
kendi çapımda küçük gözlemler yapardım.
İşte sinekleri, böcekleri,
örümcekleri incelerdim.
Çok tabii hani ufak ufak
kendi çapımda giderdim birazcık,
ama benim aslında biyolojiye
giriş yaptığım nokta burası olmuş oldu.
Ama asıl ciddi merakım benim biyolojiye,
9. sınıfta parazitlerle alakalı
bir biyoloji dersinde başladı.
Şimdi parazitler gerçekten
çok iğrenç diyebileceğimiz canlılar,
hakikaten öyle,
katılırım eğer öyle bir fikriniz varsa.
Ama her nedense benim çok ilgimi çekti
ve ben yine,
çocukluktan da gelen deneyimlerle aslında,
mikroskobun başına geçtim,
toprak örnekleri alarak bu sefer
mikroorganizmaları incelemeye başladım.
Çok ilginç.
Güzel bir deneyimdi benim için açıkçası,
ama tabii ki çok da bilime aslında
katkı sağlayamadığımı fark ettim,
bir de öyle bir isteğim vardı benim.
Bilimsel literatüre benim de,
ufak da olsa bir katkım olsun,
böyle bir isteğim vardı.
Bunun üzerine aslında şunu istedim ben;
zaten parazitlerle ilgileniyorum,
o zaman
bir araştırma projesi kurgulayayım,
büyük çaplı bir şey yapayım,
ses getirsin ve bilime de katkısı olsun.
Şimdi...
Ben 9. sınıf öğrencisiyim.
15 yaşında bir gencim.
Yani gerçi çok farklı değil,
şu anda 19 yaşındayım ama,
15 yaşındayım, nasıl bir
proje yapabilir 15 yaşında bir insan?
Kaynak bulma gibi büyük bir sorunla
karşılaşıyorsunuz öncelikle.
Yani lise öğrencisisiniz tabii ki,
her ne kadar okul veyahut da
çeşitli kurumlar destek olsa da,
bir yerde sıkışıyorsunuz.
Benim de bu sıkışıklık,
parazit örneği bulmada gerçekleşti.
Çok veteriner dolaştım,
bütün veterinerler beni tanıyordur
şu an İstanbul'da herhâlde.
Hafta sonları sürekli
veterinerlere gidiyordum,
okuldan çıkıp veterinerlere gidiyordum.
İki ay gibi bir süre aradım,
ama hiçbir sonuç olmadı maalesef.
Parazit bulamadım.
Ondan sonra dedim ki,
"Ben en iyisi bu işi,
işinde uzman olan birisine danışayım."
Kim var, derken biraz araştırma yaptım.
Amerika'da bir parazitolog varmış,
kendisi uzman tabii
parazitler üzerine çalışıyor.
Bir mail gönderdim, çok masum bir mail.
Kendimi anlattım:
"9. sınıf öğrencisiyim,
15 yaşındayım.
Çalışma yapmak istiyorum,
ne yapmam gerekiyor?" diye.
Böyle dediğim gibi
çok masum bir mail gönderdim kendisine.
Şansıma cevap geldi,
güzel de bir cevap.
Bir bana makalesini yolladı,
yani daha önce kendi yayınlamış olduğu
bir makalesini yolladı.
Çünkü şeyi de söyledi bana aslında,
"Parazitlerle çalışmak
tehlikeli olabiliyor," dedi.
Dolayısıyla hani böyle bir backup gibi
bir makalesini bana göndermiş oldu.
O makalenin içeriğine geçmeden önce
şunu söylemek istiyorum,
bu benim mailleştiğim kişi,
2015 yılında Nobel Tıp Ödülünü kazanmış
William Campbell aslında.
Yani burada şunu görüyoruz;
eğer siz kapıları çaldığınız zaman,
biraz istekli olduğunuz zaman,
yani bilgiye ulaşmak için
çaba sarf ettiğiniz zaman size dönüyorlar.
Hani Nobel'li bile olsa,
utanmadan sıkılmadan size cevap yazıyor.
Ki muhteşem bir şey bence.
Bizde birazcık bu eksiklik var
bana sorarsanız.
Her neyse, mail'i aldım.
İçindeki makaleyi gördüm.
Makalede, şimdi bakalım göreceğiz...
C. Elegans diye bir solucanla tanıştım.
Bu solucanlar zararsız
parazitlere göre tabii ki
ve çok sık olarak kullanılan canlılarmış
aslında, bunu öğrenmiş bulundum.
Araştırma projelerinde
çok sık kullanılıyorlarmış,
parazitlerin yerine tabii ki.
Ha tamam, buna ulaştık ama
şimdi çok farklı bir şey çıkıyor ortaya.
Bu sefer bunu bulmamız gerekiyor.
Sürekli bir arayış içerisindeyiz.
Proje mi yapıyoruz,
arayışta mıyız,
çok aslında
muallakta kaldığımız bir nokta.
Her neyse,
Türkiye'de çok fazla bizim tanıdığımız,
yakından bildiğimiz üniversitelerde
hocalarla görüştüm,
telefonda görüştüm çoğuyla.
Bölüm başkanlarıyla görüştüm,
ama maalesef çoğu
ya bu solucanı duymamışlar,
solucan bu arada kendisi,
ya da bazıları bana şey dedi,
"Ya oğlum nelerle uğraşıyorsun,
işte gel biz sana burada arıları verelim.
Gel kurbağalarla uğraş"
diyen oldu mesela.
Ne alaka, diyeceksiniz
Her neyse,
yani ciddiye alınmadığımı
hissettim aslında birazcık
bunun kısa anlatım şekli bu şekilde.
Ama ne oldu tabii ki,
her ne kadar kötü örnekler olsa da,
benim için çok pozitif olan
bir örnek daha var.
Bu canlıyı bulmamda
bana çok yardımcı oldu kendisi.
Oktay Kaplan adlı bir hoca Kayseri'de.
Türkiye'de, bu kadar popüler
olmasına rağmen bu canlının,
tek bu canlıyla araştırma yapan,
çalışma yapan hoca kendisiymiş Türkiye'de.
Böyle ilginç bir durum.
Bir fotoğrafımız var hatta
onu da görebilecek miyiz?
Evet, burada.
Kendisi bana çok yardımcı oldu.
İletişime geçtik,
bizi tanımamasına rağmen,
öğretmenimle beni
laboratuvarına davet etti.
Kayseri'ye gittik.
Yani proje mi yapıyoruz, ülkeyi mi
geziyoruz o da tabii tam belli değil.
Ama güzel bir deneyimdi tabii ki bu da.
Kendisinin laboratuvar ekibiyle tanıştık,
bana C. Elegans solucanlarını verdi,
başka kimyasallar da verdi.
Çok güzel bir deneyimdi,
ama tabii hani Kayseri'ye gittik,
işte yeni insanlarla tanıştık derken
projenin fikri,
benim başta aslında parazitlerle alakalı
düşündüğüm projenin fikri
çok farklı bir hâl aldı.
Bu sefer,
sıkı durun,
tip 2 diyabet
ve hipertansiyon ilaçlarındaki
etken maddelerle alakalı bir proje.
Şimdi çoğumuzda
muhtemelen vardır bu hastalıklar,
umuyorum yoktur çok fazla kişide.
Ama önemli olan iki tane etken madde var:
metformin ve kaptopril etken maddeleri.
Bu etken maddelerin insan vücudu
üzerindeki kanserle bağlantılı etkileri
aslında incelemek istediğim şeydi benim.
Şimdi bu fikir hani insanın aklına
şıp diye gelen bir fikir olmuyor tabii ki.
Nasıl gelir böyle bir fikir
insanın aklına?
Tabii ki Oktay Hocamızın desteği,
çalışmanın temelini birlikte attık,
ama onun yanısıra çok fazla
makale okuması yapmak gerekiyor.
Şimdi makale okuması
-bilimsel makalelerden bahsediyorum-
bizim çok fazla okullarda öğrencilere
yoğun olarak verdiğimiz bir şey değil.
Belki burada da bir eksiklik yaşıyoruz.
Ama tabii ben hani kendi başıma çok fazla
makale okumak durumunda kaldım tabii ki
bilimsel gelişmeleri takip etmek için.
Bir de benim ailemde vardı
hipertansiyon ve tip 2 diyabet.
Dolayısıyla bunları da birleştirerek
böyle bir sonuç ortaya çıkmış oldu.
Yani çok yorucu
bunu söylemek gerekiyor,
ama sonuçta aldığınız şey aslında
bir o kadar da ödüllendirici oluyor.
Sarf ettiğiniz efor kadar
ödül de almış oluyorsunuz.
Yani ödülden kastım tabii ki hani burada
TÜBİTAK veyahut da diğer özel
yarışmalardan kazandığım ödüller değil,
bu çalışmanın sonucu aslında.
Çünkü bilimsel literatüre yaptığım
bir katkı söz konusu benim,
öyle umuyorum yapmışızdır inşallah.
Nedir peki bu katkı diyecek olursanız;
aslında bu metformin
ve kaptopril etken maddeleri,
insan vücudunda
birlikte kullanıldıklarında,
kanser riskini arttırabiliyorlarmış.
Yani böyle bir olasılık söz konusu
ve bu bulunmuş oldu aslında,
daha önce yapılmamış bir çalışmaydı.
Ha tabii şey boyutu da var bunun,
TÜBİTAK ve diğer özel yarışmalar
boyutları da var.
Türkiye birinciliği ve bölge birinciliği
kazandım çeşitli yarışmalarda,
ama TÜBİTAK'da özellikle,
her ne kadar güzel bir şey olsa da
hani yarışma kazanmak
bölge birinciliği özellikle,
Türkiye finaline gittiğiniz zaman
beni çok üzen iki şey oldu,
bunları paylaşmak istiyorum sizlerle.
Şimdi aynı buradaki gibi orada da
jürilere sunuyorsunuz projenizi,
ben yine hararetli hararetli
anlatıyorum böyle birazcık.
Üç tane üniversite hocasından oluşan
jüri var.
Bir döndüm arkamı,
baktım iki tane hocamız
kendilerine selam gönderiyorum buradan,
kendi aralarında konuşuyorlar
ve gülüyorlar.
Şimdi ben burada ciddi bir şey yaparken,
hani çok hevesli bir şekilde proje
anlatırken bana gülünmesi açıkçası
çok doğru gelmedi,
motivasyonum kırıldı.
Bir de tabii hani sunum performansı da
aşağıya gitmeye başladı büyük oranda.
Her neyse, onu da geçtik.
Bir de tabii TÜBİTAK'ın yarışma ortamı
beni birazcık üzdü.
Çok fazla rekabet var,
çok fazla hırs söz konusu.
Orada yarışmaya katılan öğrenciler
lise öğrencileri.
İşte,
"Yarışmayı kim kazanacak,
biz mi kazanacağız,
siz mi kazanacaksınız?
Ödülü kim alacak?"
Hani bunlarla geçen bir yarışma aslında.
Ama tabii bilimsel paylaşım üzerine
kurulması gerekir.
Böyle bir eksiklik de söz konusu.
Tamam, ödüllerimizi aldık
gayet güzel.
Yani TÜBİTAK'ta bu arada tabii
Türkiye finalinde ödül alamadık maalesef.
Muhtemelen komik buldular projemi,
o sebeptendir.
Bir de şöyle bir boyut var,
ben bu çalışmanın hiçbir zaman aslında
unutulup gitmemesini istedim.
Çünkü çoğu proje, ödül alsın almasın
Türkiye'de ve yurt dışında da,
unutulup gidiyor.
Yani yarışmalardan sonra öğrenciler
devam etmiyorlar çalışmaya
ve hani proje de
çöpe gitmiş oluyor aslında.
Biraz araştırayım dedim.
Acaba bakalım Türkiye'de benim
bu çalışmayı yayınlayabileceğim
18 yaşında bir birey olarak
bir dergi var mı, mevcut mu.
Yokmuş maalesef.
TÜBİTAK'ın da yaptığı, devletin
veyahut da işte aklınıza
gelebilecek herhangi bir kurumun
böyle bir çalışması yok,
böyle bir dergisi yok.
Maalesef böyle bir şey
söz konusu değilmiş.
Ben araştırmaya devam ettim ama yine de.
Yurt dışında Journal of Emerging
Investigators diye bir dergi mevcutmuş.
Harvard Üniversitesinde
doktora ve master yapan öğrenciler
böyle bir dergi kurmuşlar.
Burada tabii şeyi görmüş onlar,
Amerika'da da bilim yarışmaları yapılıyor
ve çoğu proje unutulup gidiyor,
hani bunun önüne geçmek için böyle bir
fikir bulmuşlar, ki bence muhteşem.
Hani hemen yarın aslında
böyle bir şeye başlanabilir bile
Türkiye'de, diye düşünüyorum.
Başlanır mı, orası ayrı bir konu.
Her neyse,
ben 4.000 kelimelik projeyi çevirdim.
Hemen gönderdim
Journal of Emerging Investigators'a.
Ya ben hemen göndermeme rağmen,
4-5 aylık bir süreç sonucunda
ancak yayınlanabildi,
çünkü çok sıkı bir denetimden geçiyor
tabii ki oraya gönderilen yayınlar
ve bu sıkı denetim sonucunda da aslında,
4-5 ay süren bir denetim sonucunda
benim projem yayınlanmış oldu
ve ben yurt dışında, sağ olsunlar
böyle bir dergi kurdukları için,
18 yaşında bir birey olarak
bir yayın yapabilmiş oldum
ve bilimsel literatüre kendi çapımda
bir katkıda bulunabilmiş oldum,
ki bence çok güzel bir şey.
(Alkış)
Sağ olun.
Şimdi sizlere bahsetttiğim bütün bu süreç
11. sınıfta gerçekleşti.
Ben şu an 12. sınıftayım.
11. sınıfın sonunda da zaten,
12'ye başlamadan önce
üniversite başvuruları başlıyor.
Yurt dışının tabii ki, bizim değil.
Yurt dışı üniversitelerinin
başlamadan önce başvuruları,
ben bir vakıf okulunda okuyorum
bu arada onu da söyleyeyim,
bizim vakfın açtığı bir yarışma vardı.
Bilim alanında ben bu yarışmaya katıldım,
kazanmış bulundum
ve sonunda da eğitsel bir aktivite için
bir miktar maddi yardım kazandım
bu yarışmanın sonucunda.
Şimdi maddi yardımı ne yapabilirim diye
birazcık düşünmeye başladım ben yine.
Şöyle olabilirdi,
bir staj yapabilirdim,
ama iki opsiyon var:
yurt içinde mi, yurt dışında mı?
Şimdi yurt içinde gördüğümüz üzere,
maalesef çok ciddiye alınmıyorsunuz,
yani en azından ben alınmadım.
E, gülüyorlar veyahut da işte
insanlara ulaşamıyorsunuz çoğu zaman.
E, dolayısıyla ben dedim bu sefer
bir yurt dışında şansımı deneyeyim.
Almanya'da Max Planck Enstitüleri vardır.
Birçok Max Planck Enstitüsü var.
Ben bunlardan yaklaşık
15-20 tanesine mail gönderdim.
CV'mi hazırlamıştım zaten,
CV'mi ekledim,
makalemin yayınlanmış formatını ekledim.
Staj yapmak istiyorum diye,
beni alır mısınız diye
böyle yine çok masum bir şekilde
mail gönderdim.
20 tane gönderdim diyelim,
19 tanesi beni reddetti.
İşte çeşitli sebeplerden dolayı;
işte yerimiz yok veyahut da tarihler uygun
değil gibi çeşitli sebeplerden dolayı
bana yer sağlayamadılar maalesef.
Devam ettim göndermeye,
biraz inatçıyımdır.
Onun da belki bir etkisi oldu
pozitif olarak tabii ki.
20.'sinde bana cevap geldi
olumlu, iki hafta boyunca bizim yanımızda
staj yapabilirsin diye
Max Planck
Evrimsel Biyoloji Enstitüsü'nden.
Şimdi burada aslında şunu görüyoruz;
biraz inatçılık aslında
çok da zararlı olmayan bir şey,
aksine yararlı olan bir şey.
Dolayısıyla hani kapıları çalalım,
istekli olalım.
Genç araştırmacılar adına
söylüyorum tabii ki
ve bu da aslında sonuç veriyor,
çok da olumlu sonuçlar veriyor.
Bunu da yaptık,
iki hafta boyunca staj yaptım orada.
Ondan sonra zaten üniversite başvuru
süreci artık başlamış bulunuyor.
Ben erken başvuruda Harvard Üniversitesine
başvurmaya karar vermiştim.
Yalnız şunu da
söylemek istiyorum tabii ki,
yurt dışı üniversitelerinin
şöyle güzel bir yanı var
Amerika'dakilerin, Kanada'dakilerin,
İngiltere'dekilerin ortak bir yanı bu.
Bir öğrenciyi alacakları zaman;
2-3 saatlik bir sınavda
göstereceği başarıya göre değil,
komple bir insan olarak, bir birey olarak
kabul ediyorlar ederlerse.
"Bütünsel değerlendirme" diyorlar buna da.
Hani ne dahildir bütünsel değerlendirmeye;
öğretmenlerinizden alacağınız
tavsiye mektupları,
efendime söyleyeyim yazacağınız
kompozisyonlar kendinizi anlatan,
kazandığınız ödüller varsa eğer,
liderlik aktiviteleri,
okulda girdiğiniz kulüpler...
Yani komple bir insan olarak
değerlendiriliyorsunuz,
ki bu da muhteşem bir şey
ve bu değerlendirme sonucunda,
ben zaten başvurmuştum
Harvard Üniversitesine,
sonuç olarak da Harvard Üniversitesinden
%100 burslu kabul aldım.
Stanford Üniversitesinden de
Teşekkür ederim, sağ olun.
(Alkış)
(Islık)
Annem olabilir o.
Islık annemden gelmiş olabilir.
Güzel bir sonuç oldu tabii ki.
Ama hani
başarılı diyebileceğimiz bir sonuç,
ama şunu da biliyorum tabii ki
Türkiye'de benim ulaştığım başarının
çok daha büyük bir başarıya
ulaşabilecek öğrenciler var;
gerek devlet okullarında okuyan,
gerek özel kurumlarda
farklı okullarda okuyan.
Yani çok büyük bir potansiyel söz konusu.
Bizim yaptıklarımızdan çok daha iyisini
başarabilecek öğrenciler var,
ama işte sizlere aslında
bahsettiğim sebeplerden dolayı,
biraz o potansiyel
çöpe gidiyor gibi hissediyorum.
Ki ziyan olmaması gereken
bir potansiyel bu.
Bunun için ne yapılabilir?
İşte TÜBİTAK olabilir,
devlet olabilir.
Yani topyekün aslında
bir seferberlik oluşturup
bilime ve eğitime olan desteği
arttırmamız gerekiyor
bu potansiyelin ziyan olmaması için.
Nasıl yapabiliriz bunu,
somut örnek isterseniz;
belki her okulda, lisede, orta okulda
birer laboratuvar olsa
tamamen araştırma projelerine,
kimya fizik biyolojiye,
tamamen araştırma projesi yapmaya
odaklanmış birer laboratuvar olsa,
veyahut da yani benzer şeyler yapılabilir.
Eğitime harcanan para artsa,
diyebiliriz mesela.
Ama şunu da söylemek gerekiyor;
ben bu süreçte çok şanslıydım,
çünkü çocukluğumdan beri annem, ailem
benim eğitimime çok destek oldu,
sorgulamayı aşılattılar bana.
Ben yine çok şanslıydım, çünkü %100 burslu
olarak bir lisede okuyordum
Türkiye'nin en iyi liselerinden
bir tanesinde.
Yine çok şanslıydım,
çünkü bütün bu proje sürecinde
bana destek olan Belgin hocam vardı.
Kendisine teşekkür etmeden
geçmek istemiyorum.
Ama dediğim gibi,
çok büyük bir potansiyel mevcut
ve bunun da aslında ziyan olmasının
önüne geçmemiz gerekiyor
hemen şimdi diye düşünüyorum.
Ki bunun için de ben Amerika'da
eğitimimi tamamladıktan sonra
-üzerine master, doktora da
yapmayı düşünüyorum-
Türkiye'ye dönüp tekrar
eğitim ve bilim alanında
elimden geldiğini yapmak için
çok hevesliyim.
Elimden geleni de yapacağım inşallah.
(Alkış)
Sağ olun.